AMRIT SANJEEV: Hello.
I'm Amrit Sanjeev from
the Developer Show.
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Android P beta two
is now available.
This update includes a final
Android P APIs, the latest
system images, and
updated developer tools
to help you get ready for the
customer release coming later
in the summer.
For more details on
machine learning,
simplicity, polish, and
security in this release,
head over to the post linked
in the description below.
We advise developers to use keys
generated on the user device
to encrypt push
messages end to end,
but implementing such
end-to-end encryption
has historically required
significant technical knowledge
and effort, which is why we're
excited to announce Capillary
open-source library
to greatly simplify
the implementation of
end-to-end encryption of push
messages between
the developer server
and the user's Android devices.
For more details
and to get started,
take a look at the post.
Chrome 68 Beta is now
available and includes
a new Add to Home
Screen behavior
for Progressive Web Apps, the
payment handler API, the page
lifecycle API, and more.
Take a look at the post
for all the details,
including screenshots and code.
We recently announced changes
including our new simplified
maps, routes, and places
products, as well as
new pricing plans to make
our products easier to use
and more scalable as you grow.
Make sure to visit the
post for the three steps
that you need to take
prior to June 11.
Sole-tenant nodes are now
available on Google Compute
Engine in beta.
Sole-tenant nodes are physical
compute engines servers
designed for your dedicated use.
Normally, [INAUDIBLE]
instances run
on physical hosts that may
be shared by many customers.
With sole-tenant nodes, you
have the host all to yourself.
Check out the post
to get started.
Last week, New Orleans hosted
the North American Association
for Computational
Linguistics Conference, which
is a venue for the
latest research
on computational
approaches to understanding
national language.
We presented our research
on a diverse set of topics,
including dialog, summarization,
machine translation,
and linguistic analysis.
Take a look at the post
linked in the description
below for the links to
the papers and more.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Amrit Sanjeev for
the Developer Show.
Thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]